[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had started
with our derivation of the classical
plate theory equations
and we had reached this stage in this
lecture we are
going to continue from exactly this
place
[Music]
now the steps that we are going to do
in this lecture when i do this in a real
face-to-face classroom on a chalkboard
even there it is uh fairly challenging
because uh although the steps themselves
are not that difficult
uh they are quite long
now i have never done this on a on a
writing app before
so it is going to be a bit of a
challenge to me also
but i'll try my best to keep things
under control
okay so with that brief preamble
uh let us try to get to the
business end of things what i'll do is
i'll copy paste
this line and start off with the
steps in the next page
all right
um the first thing that i'm going to do
is to transpose this negative sign to
this left hand side
making all the terms positive
all right next what i'm going to do
uh is to play a little algebra or a
calculus kind of
manipulation wherein i'll rewrite
each of these terms in a certain fashion
so let me show that to you
instead of describing it
i'll try to write it a little bit small
so that things can be kept under control
within the limited space that i have
here
so you see what i just did the term
which was mx del square w del x
square i have rewritten it in this
fashion
meaning that i have actually
artificially
uh incorporated an extra term
like del mx del x times
del w del x because if you if you
break it up you will get this term but
you'll also get that extra term
but i don't want that because i want
there to be an equality between this
step
and the previous step so i have to
subtract this out
[Music]
let me write that as a separate
integration
all right next
for this term i'll do exactly the same
thing
so you see the steps are a bit
repetitive
but because there are so many terms
we have to be a little bit careful in
keeping track
of what term is going where
but they are not that difficult
in themselves
all right for this last term what i'm
going to do
you see i have two options in my hand i
can either
select this del del x to operate in the
way that i have done here
or i can choose the del del y to operate
in the way that i have done here but i
also have
this twice so there are two terms
involved here
so what i'll do is i'll choose one of
them and use the del del x
root and i'll choose the other term and
choose the
del del y root and you will see
eventually the benefit
of proceeding in that fashion
so first of all
going down the del del x route
so what is left inside is this del w del
y
and then i compensate for the extra term
incurred
by subtracting out this term
all right next i go down the del del y
root for the
other term
this time within the bracket i will have
del w del
x correspondingly
i have to subtract out this term
with the partial derivative with respect
to y
all right so you see uh it is not that
difficult to understand it just it's
just long
okay uh now is the part where
we will actually use uh something rather
clever
and uh something which is uh fairly
advanced
as far as engineering mathematics is
concerned okay
so this is sometimes referred to
as the greens theorem and it has a
direct connection with something which
you are already familiar with
uh called the gauche divergence theorem
uh and that is something which we have
been using
all throughout our course on applied
elasticity and we have also been using
it
uh previously in this lecture in this
course itself
so what we say here is that
a brief interlude
a brief interlude regarding
spring's theorem
now if you just search on wikipedia
about green's theorem
i'm sure you will get a sort of version
which may not
exactly look the way that i am
presenting it here
but if you just apply your head a little
bit
and try to see the correspondence you
will see that they are basically the
same
okay so what we are what we are going to
say is this that suppose
i have an integration over an area
which is in this fashion del p del x
okay plus
del u del y
where each of these p and
q are themselves functions of
x and y so this is an integration with
respect to the
uh to the entire domain to the entire
area so this thing
this area integration will be equal to
an integration over the periphery of
this area
or over the contour of this area
and where the integrand it changes
like this where
please note that this nx and this
ny are the x component and the y
component of the unit outward normal
to the uh to the contour so let me
draw that diagram so it will be a little
bit clearer
so suppose we are looking at this kind
of an
area so in just the next slide what i'm
going to do is
of course consider this general area to
be this
area that is occupied by our plate
up so we'll be able to use the green's
theorem in this step
but just look at the theorem right now
right now
so this is our entire area a and this
boundary here that is the s
s is the boundary is the area okay
and what i'm saying here is that the
unit outward normal
at any generic point that is given by
this n hat
and the x component of that
is an x and the y component of that
is ny all right
so this green's theorem basically
gives us a method of going
from an area integration to a line
integration
so you see that this integration is only
over
this periphery is over this contour so
this is basically
a line integration or a line integral so
just like
uh in the uh when we're using the
pause divergence theorem it gives us a
method
of going from a volume integral to an
area integral in the similar fashion
this green's theorem uh it gives us a
method
of going from the area integration to
the line integration
all right uh
you can also reinterpret
this term here as
the gradient of some vector
of let's say some
some r vector okay where this
r vector is equal to
p i hat plus u j hat
okay and because this gradient
now of course this is the two
dimensional gradient this gradient
is the del del x i hat plus
del del y j hat
[Music]
this gradient is like that
if you take the divergence of this
r vector so del dot r or the grad dot
r you are going to end up with this
thing here and on the right hand side
what we have written
is basically r dot
n okay so you can i can
can understand that
this is what we are basically writing
and written in this fashion it is
somewhat reminiscent
of what we had done back uh
in our cause divergence theorem it's
it's reminiscent it's not exactly the
same
because there we were going from the
volume integral to the area integral
and here we are going from the area
integral to the line integral
okay now uh is the is the point where we
are going to utilize this thing and you
see how we are going to utilize it
first of all uh we have this term here
so
if you just forget about what if it is
inside here
and you just think of it like this del
del x of something here
and then you consider this term where
you have a del del y of
another thing here and then if you
consider this term together with this
term
then perhaps that would be a good way of
proceeding
with the application of the queen's
theorem
okay because we can take this area
integration
together with this area integration club
these two terms together
and then rewrite those terms in the next
step
in the form of this line integration
in a similar fashion uh we can
we can proceed with uh we can proceed
with
uh maybe this term and this term
all right and then uh reduce that also
okay so let's see uh how much we can
simplify what terms we are left with
and what further steps we can take
all right so what i'll do is
i will again uh copy paste this entire
thing
you see why it is a bit challenging to
write this in this
writing app in a chalkboard
i would have fairly good amount of real
estate
to make these things
visually more comfortable okay
we'll have to make the best use of
whatever we have and then proceed
so what we have here is this minus lhs
bending
all right so
uh
i am going to consider first of all
this term together with this term
and then by the application of the
queen's theorem
let me just check if i think i've missed
a delta here
let me just check
so earlier i did have a delta over here
i have
added delta and delta so i did miss that
there was a little bit of a mistake at
the end of the previous video
but no matter we'll correct it here
you will have to correct it here also
and i'll have to correct it here also
i think it will be uh
it'll be easier if i just
select this delta w
and copy paste it wherever necessary
so sorry about testing your patients
like this but this is something that
needs to be corrected
and finally for this term also
all right i think i have i'm done there
uh so
i think i'll have to copy paste this
term now
instead of this
go back and copy paste this
okay that should do it
all right so i'm going to consider this
term
and this term
so this is m x del delta w
d x n x plus
m y
del delta w del y
in y and now this integration becomes
a line integration that is over
the entire boundary of our plate
next uh i'm going to consider
this term together with
this term
and what i'm going to obtain is m x y
from here in this del delta w
l y n x plus
this term m x y
del delta w del x
and y and this also gets converted to
a line integration and the terms that i
have
that i'm left with are these this one
this one this one here and this one here
okay uh
so let me just write those out
now uh as you can anticipate
uh what we are going to do here
is uh is basically
to uh to consider these terms
in uh in again the same fashion that we
have been
uh using the greens theorem earlier
okay so the the idea here is to
ultimately
go to a term which will involve
the delta w only without
uh any of these derivatives so
in this sense what we are doing here
is basically corresponding to what we
did back in beam theory
when we went ahead with the integration
by parts
because as a result of the integration
by parts what we ended up
obtaining was some boundary terms
and then some integration terms over the
entire domain
so in exactly the same fashion as you
see that
after the application of the greens
theorem
what we have uh actually ended up here
at least over these two terms is that
these
are integrations no doubt but they are
integrations only over the boundaries
okay so they are they are special kind
of integration they are over the
boundaries so going ahead uh
our plan is to again use the greens
theorem
such that we will be one step closer to
obtaining terms
which will involve the first variation
of w
but they will be devoid of any such
partial derivatives
okay so in order to reduce the steps
what i will do is i will
i will skip one step that the step that
i was going to write and skip it
and then directly apply the greens
theorem on this term
on this term on this term and on this
term so all the remaining terms that i
have not yet written here
for for those i'm going to apply the
greens theorem
okay so
first of all considering this term
so you see it already comes with a minus
here so
in order to adjust the artificially
introduced term
what i have to do is use this kind
of a compensating term
and that will be in the form of
this so the extra term that we have
introduced here is this del square
mx del x square which is exactly what i
have written here
we have just taken care of this term
next
we are going to consider this one
these are all area integrations because
we have not yet used
the green's theorem we are just
rewriting the terms
now i'm rewriting this term here
again it appears with the plus because i
already have a minus here
and now the compensating terms
all right uh
for this term oh sorry
on this term i'm going to write it now
so i'm done with this term also
for this term
i have these
there should be a d a over here
and then a compensating term
like so we are done with
this term also and finally
for this term
all right so as i had mentioned earlier
we do have to keep track of a lot of
terms but there is a little
bit of a good news here in the sense
that you see
this term here and this term here they
are the same
so at least something is going to be
reduced in the next step
in the form okay twice uh
regarding the rest of the terms you see
uh
this is the point where we use the
greens theorem again
okay because in the next step uh this
first term here
and this second term here they are not
going to change
so whatever we have already obtained in
the form of line integrals
they are going to remain as it is
these terms we wish to
combine them these terms involving the
area integration so we wish to combine
them in a fashion
such that they will be amenable for uh
for the use of the green's theorem okay
now
uh which way should we go that is the
question
well uh
you see uh we do have a few
uh i mean a couple of different options
for example one could think that perhaps
one could combine this
with this because all that we need is a
term
involving the del del x of something and
the delta y of another thing
so we do have an option over there
considering this and this
so let me just number the terms so it
will be easier to keep track of
uh i'm not going to number these earlier
terms
rather i'm going to number the terms on
which
i am going to apply the green's theorem
so this is these are the terms here
uh and this okay so please note
that i do have other area integrations
this one
this one this one and this one
but i don't have any intention of
applying the greens theorem over there
okay they will just get combined
now what as i was saying i wish to
combine
these terms in such a fashion that and
they will be amenable for the
application of green's theorem
so should i combine one
and two that is certainly 1 root
or should i combine 1 and 3 so the root
that i am going to choose
is to combine this 1 and 2.
and correspondingly i will just combine
this three and four
okay so for the application of green's
theorem uh let me just state it
clearly and unambiguously that i'm going
to combine
this uh term one with this
term two and i'm going to combine term
three
with this term four okay the rest of the
terms
i'm going to keep as it is all right
so uh
what i'll do here uh in this
this step
i think it will be just easier if i if i
copy this entire thing and go to the
next slide
okay
this is still minus lhs bending
these terms these first two terms then
i'm going to keep
capacitives
okay so
i might as well copy paste them
all right next combining this one and
two
uh what i'm going to get
is this del mx
del x delta w
nx plus
del m y del y
from this term to delta w
and y this entire thing becomes a line
integration
next combining the term three with term
four
ah so we have to be a little bit careful
here
you see this here although it appears
uh before this term but this is
uh a derivative with respect to y
okay so what we need to be careful here
is to
write this as n ny
and this is derivative with respect to x
so i'm talking about this derivative
here
and this derivative the one outside the
first bracket okay
so that is again
a line integration and all the terms
that we're left with
i'll club them together because all of
them are area integrations
and all of them have as their
coefficients this
delta w okay so
i'm done with this term now
next considering this one
and next i'll combine this and this
this entire thing has have as its
coefficient delta w
and this integration remains an area
integration
all right
now it seems to us
that all the applications of the greens
theorem that we
could have possibly done we have done
uh we have reduced a number of terms to
integrations over the not over the
domain but over the
periphery of the domain or the boundary
of the domain so these
are going to eventually uh contribute to
some kinds of boundary terms and we'll
see them
but for now our interest will focus our
interest
for our attention uh to
uh to perhaps uh seeing if it is
possible to uh to simplify
these things okay because you see
uh the motivation for for such a step
okay so as
a precursor to the next step let me just
state the motivation
back in beam theory we certainly did not
write
uh any moment terms the
all the simplifications and all the
steps that we did
uh where involving uh
involved directly the the bending
variable which was w and
you see embedded within this mx my and
mxy which have been defined using the
sigma xx sigma yy and sigma xy
we do have the presence of the strains
to the stress strain relations and
further those strain
expressions can be written in terms of
the displacement variable so there is
some hope that these terms here
can be converted somehow in terms of the
displacement variables
okay so let's see how we can do that
so this will be once with this doing
such a thing
will be taking us one step closer
towards obtaining a governing
differential equation
in terms of the displacement variables
much in the same way that we were able
to do
back in our bending theory all right so
what we are going to do is we'll stop
with the
with the uh with the process of
going further with these steps we will
come back here but for now we are going
to take up
each of these mx my and mxy
all right so first of all
for mx we note
that as we had written earlier this was
our definition minus h by 2 to h by 2
sigma x x z dz
now sigma xx uh back in our first
lecture on
or back in our previous lecture we had
uh already written them uh written it in
terms of
the epsilon x6 and epsilon yy you can
refer that back
the expression was e
by 1 minus nu square
epsilon x x plus nu epsilon y y
and then we have the z d z
now the epsilon x x and epsilon y v
y y we are going to replace
in terms of uh the displacement
variables
and let's see what simplification that
affords us
or what expressions we end up with so
epsilon xx
uh it was uh
del u s del x
minus z
del square w del x square
and this nu
[Music]
uh epsilon yy this epsilon yy
was del vs
del y minus z
del square w del y square
and i should not forget this poisons
ratio because this mu is
multiplied over this entire epsilon yy
okay
and then i have this z dz
now you see we have this integration
over the symmetric domain
minus h by 2 to h by 2 symmetric about a
z equal to zero
so all the terms which are odd in
the variable z they are going to vanish
which means that this del u s del x
which by itself is independent of z
but that is multiplied by this z so this
is z to the power 1 which makes
this term here multiplied with the z and
odd
function all over this over this domain
of z equal to minus h by 2 to h by 2
or about 0 so that term is going to
vanish
similarly this term where this v s also
is independent of z
so that just leaves this multiplied with
z to the power 1
so that is also an odd function
effectively and that also vanishes
these terms however there is a z already
present here
so that multiplied by this z will result
in a z square
so that makes this term over here even
though this w
is independent of this w
independent offset but because of the
presence of the z square over here and
the z squared over here
this term and this term they are going
to be even functions
and they are going to not vanish so
what we are going to end up with
is this thing so
its let me just rewrite that
taking the minus outside
up in fact i can take the z square
common between these terms
so that i'll be
left with this
so that ultimately i can in fact take
this term out of the
integration with respect to z i can take
this and that thing
outside of the integration with respect
to z
and what i'll be left with here is this
integration with respect to z
minus h by 2 to h by 2
and that thing is is going to give me
uh so i'll just do it in the
rough column here in order to save some
space
so this is going to give me a z
cube by 3
limits h by two lower limit h minus h by
two
uh so this is one by three that is z
cube so this is h cubed by eight
times two so that is eventually
h cube by 12. so
what i have here is e h cube
by 12 1 minus nu square
and then whatever was present inside the
bracket
all right in exactly the same fashion
if we proceed with the m y
whose definition was like this
we are eventually going to end up with a
term
which looks exactly the same as the mx
except for a little difference which you
can almost expect
that it is instead of the del squared w
del x
square first we have this thing and then
we have the poisons ratio multiplied
by this thing
all right next
let us not forget the and that is going
to be a slightly different term
but we'll take care of it
this is sigma x y z d z
and sigma x y is
twice g epsilon x y
z dz
now g is e divided by
2 into 1 plus nu this we had learned
back in our applied elasticity course
and epsilon x y that is
half del
u s del y
plus del v s del x
minus twice z del squared w
del x del y
and that is multiplied by z
with respect to z so you see just like
we had in the case of the mx this term
over here
and this term over here they are
multiplied by the z
so they eventually contribute to odd
functions
so they uh so this integration from
minus h by 2 to h by 2 makes
their contributions to vanish and
ultimately
oh by the way uh i think i missed a
minus here
so bad mistake it should come with a
minus because i had a minus over here
okay in a similar fashion i will have a
minus over here
now i'm coming back to this thing so
now you see uh what i'm going to get
here
is uh you see
this two it cancels with this two this
two
it cancels with this two all right
these two terms they vanish and
ultimately what we are
going to have is just again this kind of
an integration because this said
multiplied with this that gives such a
red square d
z and this term note del square w del x
del y
is just independent of z okay so
what we are going to end up with here is
this e divided by 1 plus
nu del square
w del x del y
and then integration z square dz
over limit minus h by 2 upper limit h by
2
and that of course that means the minus
sign
again so uh ultimately this is again
going to give me this
h cube by 12 so eventually i'm going to
end up with this minus
e h cubed by 12 into 1 plus nu
and then this del square w del x
del y so this is the term
so this this expression here this
expression over here
and this expression here that i wish to
substitute
back in back in these terms
only in these terms to see what sort of
simplification
that uh that it it gives us
okay so let me just quickly try to do
that
in the next slide i'll just copy paste
out this part
so this is one luxury that i certainly
did not have
uh back when using the chalkboard
so i lose some i gained some
okay i wish to obtain
the expression for this particular
combination of this expression
uh this the version of this in terms of
the uh the w so this is
del square del x square
this is minus e h cube by
12 into 1 minus nu square
and then l square w del x square
plus nu l square w del y
square
next for this term i have
del square del y square
again
but this time del square w del y square
plus nu del square w
del x square
and finally for this i have twice
l squared l x del y
and within bracket i'll have minus e h
cubed
by 12 into 1 plus nu
del square w del x
l y okay
so uh if i i just
let me see if i can simplify this a
little bit
so one thing is good here that i have
this eh cube by 12
this minus each cube by 12 common um
[Music]
and i'll also take this 1 minus mu
square common uh
only i have to compensate with the 1
minus 2 in the in the numerator
let's do this so i'll take this minus h
cube by 12
into 1 minus nu square common
and
this gives me a del 4w del x4
so i'm operating this on this
all right i'm done with that
next for this i have
del 4 w del y 4
plus del or
w del y square del
x square and for this
i'm going to have uh let me not forget
this 1 minus nu
because i have taken this 1 minus nu
square in the denominator common but i
only had a 1 plus nu
so i'm effectively multiplying a 1 minus
mu here
but to take that common i'll have to
compensate by a 1 minus 2 in the
numerator
so
you see this term here and this term
here that gives me a twice nu del 4 w
del x
square del y square and uh
i have forgotten this 2 over here i'll
correct that
okay so you see there is a minus 2 new
del 4 w del x square del y square here
so this term here this term here and
this term here with the with the new
they cancel and eventually
i am going to end up with
a certain nice looking expression
which is this
because i'll have this twice of del 4 w
del x
square del y square still remaining i'll
have to write that
you see it is a nice expression it is a
really nice expression
because these this term here this
is uh something quite familiar to us
especially from our course on
applied elasticity you recognize that
this is the by harmonic term okay so
this is the by harmonic operator
operating on
r on w okay so
this can indeed be written in this
fashion
okay so uh
another thing is that this particular
combination
without the minus this e h cubed by 12
into one minus nu square
that particular combination is given a
certain name it is called the bending
rigidity
i mean it is so very important within
studies
of plate theory
so ah that is given a special name here
so this d
uh equal to e h cubed
by 12 into one minus nu squared uh
that is referred to as the bending
rigidity
all right so
if we just go back
to this over here you'll see that this
term
it has gotten expressed uh in terms of
that minus the
delta for w so there is a certain
simplification
possible here and please note that in
light of what i had
mentioned earlier
these terms are eventually what are
going to
[Music]
lead to our governing differential
equations or contribute to our governing
differential equation
and because they have now been expressed
in terms of this bending rigidity and
this
on this operator w you see that
it is actually shaping up uh to a nice
form and and the last and then the final
governing equation that we are going to
end up with
they they they'll have a certain
symmetry and niceness to it
but we are going to cover or we are
going to complete those steps
in the in the next video so
on that note i will i will end this
fairly long
video thank you very much